he's a decorated retired Navy SEAL
officer he received the silver and
Bronze Star for his service in the Iraq
war he is the author of several books
and he hosts the jhaqo podcast
he's Jocko a Lincoln here's my take on
his top ten rules a success vol 9
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one fight on what do I do
when I'm broken when I'm broken I relish
it that's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
use it because if I'm broken then I just
found my limitations and until I know
what my limitations are how can i push
him how can I get better but once once I
see it once I feel it once I see where I
was broken then I can attack that
weakness I can fill in that gap I can
reinforce that breach if you break it
means it's time to fortify your will to
make it stronger then look there's
there's all kinds of different ways to
break you can break physically you can
break mentally you can break your heart
you can break your spirit and none of
those are fun and all of those are gonna
leave a mark
but the mark that they leave can be the
mark of victory or it can be the mark of
defeat because every time you break in
in every way that you break wow it's a
chance it's definitely a chance for you
to give up and for you to just to fall
apart but there's also opportunity
there's opportunity to get stronger and
get smarter and get faster and get
tougher and get more stable and get more
resilient and get better in fact if you
break the fight is just beginning and as
you are all up and out of that dismal
and wretched place covered and your
offer in blood and sweat and dirt and
filth as you rise above what you were
and as you take the form of of who you
are supposed to be you will see that in
the very act of standing up in the very
act of fighting on you will become and
you will remain unbroken rule number two
focused on the things that matter you
can put so much working above so much
focus on working that you lose track of
your family yeah and everything goes
down tail with your family or you can do
the opposite put so much focus on your
family that you lose track of that you
don't do what you're supposed to do at
work so you need to back off a little
and you get people that waste time on
things that don't matter
mm-hmm this goes back to remember the
podcast we did where I was talking about
how like a black belt when a white belt
collabing grabbing
black belts leave and it just doesn't
matter there's people that think that
did it's important that I do this thing
this certain way and the reality is it's
useless it doesn't matter you're being
OCD mmm right you're being OCD so or you
maybe not being full OC but you're being
borderline you've got to think about
what's important what's not important
and if your disability generally or
oftentimes people that are hyper
disciplined about little things a lot of
times they're missing their discipline
in other areas of their life and one of
them and and you we've talked about this
before too which is somebody that just
because someone is hyper disciplined in
their physical fitness doesn't mean that
they're disciplined in their rest of
their life in many other ways whether
it's financial whether it's their
relationships whatever like everything
is they can be screwing every they're
super disciplined in weighing their food
and doing macro calorie counting and all
that stuff right and yet they haven't
paid their phone bill or whatever and
they've got financial issues or they've
got health like other health issues and
so you need that you need to back off
enough on the little things that don't
matter that so that the things that
matter you can actually take care of
little number three learn from mistakes
I had the opportunity to go to fight to
flight school but instead tested
positive on a drug test and I was given
a general discharge I of course take
full responsibility and feel like an
idiot how would you recommend moving
past this failure well if my seal career
had ended with a mistake I would have
figured out what my next mission was
going to be that's that's what I would
have done I mean I would have said okay
I like that job I failed at it what can
I learn from that and what can I do next
differently to make sure I don't make
that mistake again
I'm gonna learn from the past but I'm
not gonna dwell on it mmm there's no
point in dwelling on it
the only point in dwelling on just to
learn from it so that's what I would do
here and then I would take what I
learned from my experiences of
I failed and I would also take the
positive things that I learned because
you even that even that failure is a
positive even that failure is a positive
cuz you realize you realize the value of
the opportunity that you had and you
blew it and you're like okay I'm never
to let that happen to get a lesson
learned I'm gonna actually Stoke they
get to learn that lesson because it's
gonna be more opportunities that come up
in life and you got to make sure that
you don't disregard those opportunities
when they come up and so I would have
taken those lessons learned take that
take that failure and turn it into
something positive and made good things
happen when I figure out what my new
mission a new career was gonna be rule
number four just do more when you you've
crushed your daily to-do list do you
then take the time to relax or do you
attack the next day's list is that
against prioritize and execute since the
mission is done for the day you know
just do more just keep going even if
it's going do more if you have extra
time do whatever you can do to stay
ahead and I do that pretty much until
I'm brain dead and I can definitely work
myself into it until I'm brain dead like
I can get to a point where I'm reading
or I'm writing it just it's just it's
just done I'm done and so I just have to
stop and take a break then I'll go do
something mindless for a while you know
so you know if you if you got stuff to
do keep hammering until you can't hammer
anymore and then say okay you know what
I need a little breather and then take a
little breather and then get back to it
also if you want to learn to have more
confidence check out my 254 series it's
free the link is in the description
below people want to know how to stop
the laziness and they want to know how
to stop the procrastination rule number
five make a change people that are quit
drinking and quit doing drugs and quit
losing their temper and I've heard from
so many different people that have
implemented change in their lives so so
many letters and messages and notes and
I want you to know that these people
aren't a bunch of of elite Special
Operations warriors that's not who who
they are they aren't a bunch of
high-level
athletes or highly screened in highly
trained individuals these are just just
normal people really but they're normal
people that knew they needed to make a
change and they decided they were going
to make a change and then they made it
and that is what I do and that is what
you can do too if you have something to
change if you want to change something
change it change it now rule number six
be a good leader so what you have to be
do what you have to do is don't be
offensive when you take ownership when
you take ownership you can't be
offensive when you take ownership some
people get offended by that so when you
say hey you know what this is mine I got
this that bothers some people when you
say you know what this is my fault now
I'm gonna fix it that even that offends
some people what the tone just a tone
yeah of like no this is my fault I got
this you do that three dance three times
four times five times it's awesome
because oh what everything's his fault
not he's gotta fix everything they he
doesn't think I can fix it right
you can offend people with with all
kinds of stuff you have to work very
hard to offend people I mean there's
people get offended when you say
something nice to him even when you're
taking ownership people can actually be
offended by that if you go too far so
instead of overtly stepping up and
taking ownership in this particular case
and you can tell what what's going on
here my brother here young warehouse
manager he's fired up he wants to make
things happen he wants to get after it
and so what does he do he's like oh I
read extreme ownership I'm gonna take
ownership of everything and that's a
great attitude to have except for
can offend people when you go too far
because you got to read the second book
that I got so that you could you can
balance that out a little bit so instead
of saying like hey this is mine I'm
gonna take ownership of this and make it
happen
instead you you know you look at someone
you you say hey you know what do you
want me to take care of this oh hey you
know what that's probably in my
department you want me to take care of
that so that way
yeah or like hey it seems like this
should be something I should take care
of you want me to handle that instead of
me me me me rule number seven be
well-rounded I'm a seventeen year old
I'm a blue belt in jujitsu which I
received a few days after my 16th
birthday and I have ambitions of
pursuing jujitsu professionally and
competing to the highest level possible
of course this requires discipline and
commitment I miss parties and social
events in order to stranger Jitsu and
wait train because I know that I should
have the discipline to do so however I
feel lonely and isolated because of it
is this just weakness or should I make
the occasional exception for a social
event
if you can't like communicate with
people effectively that's a real problem
in any environment mmm right and if
you're isolating yourself from other
people and you're not you're not
learning how to interact with other
human beings in a social environment
that's not good and it's not only it's
not only that it's it's not only that
it's just not good for you because yes
you as a person you need to be
well-rounded you need to be yes you need
to be strong you need to be capable from
a fighting perspective but you also need
to be smart you need to be articulate
you need to be quick-witted and those
things are mandatory skills in life I
mean if you're a black belt in jujitsu
and you're a white belt in communicating
with other human beings that's not going
to be a good situation for you and the
other thing is the better you are the
more well-rounded you are in all these
other aspects life those things will
actually make you better at jujitsu too
because you'll be able to read people
you'll be able to deal with
confrontation you'll be able to
understand other people's motivations
and all those things come from
interacting with other human beings so I
get it I get the massive commitment
and that is what it takes like if you
want to compete at the highest level I'm
telling you yes you have to live breathe
and eat jiu-jitsu you have to live
breathe and eat conditioning and that
being said if that's all you live
breathe and eat that's gonna make you
less apt to be a champion than if you
make yourself a little bit more
well-rounded in some of these other
aspects rule number eight question
leadership a soldier should always
question their leaders not just their
leaders values but their leaders plans
their leader strategies their leaders
vision you should question everything
that your leader is telling you and if
you see something is wrong then you
should raise your hand and call it out
and I would say not only is it something
that you should do it's actually your
duty it's actually your duty is to raise
your hand as a soldier and I'll tell you
this doesn't only apply to the military
it applies to any organization and it
might sound like I'm encouraging mutiny
or rebellion but actually the opposite
is true if you have a team that
questions the leader the leader doesn't
become weaker the leader becomes
stronger if he's a good leader if he's
on the right path he's doing the right
thing he becomes stronger because
everyone starts to understand why things
are happening they understand the vision
more fully if the leader doesn't have a
good vision and he's getting questioned
and he can't answer the questions yeah
he might have a mutiny on his hands but
it's not because the people are asking
questions because he doesn't know what
he's doing
rule number nine yet disciplined one
lesson do you wish you'd have learned
earlier in life that you now know is
this funny cause for you I mean that is
the thing that that when I connected
that together in my head that the fact
that that applies to absolutely
everything that's the biggest lesson
that I wish I would have learned earlier
in life and if I would have figured that
out
and I would have been doing a lot better
and I would have done a lot better I
would have been a lot better of a person
kids in mind this is something that I
completely missed as a kid the actions
that you take now affect your future
that sounds so obvious but when you're
14 you just think no nothing I you know
my life is only another 20 minutes so
what I'm doing right now does it really
matter so when I talk to kids I try and
explain to them the discipline equals
freedom and then I try to explain to
them that what you're doing right now
really will have an impact to where you
are in the future and I don't know if
you listen to that podcast that I do it
the warrior kid podcast that I did in
number 19 about my friend Jeff and I
talked about it on the adult podcast as
well but you know it's a classic story I
had a best friend when I was little and
we separated friendship not we were
still friends but we we drifted apart he
started getting into party and getting
into drugs and all that and I didn't and
his trajectory in life just went down
and I joined the Navy which was great
and it put me on a good path or almost
involuntarily but he ended up he ended
up killing himself and you know he was
drugs it was alcohol and it was just bad
but while I was going through buds he
killed himself and what I tried to
explain to the kids on the warrior kid
podcast is like the decisions that the
little decisions that you make
they matter they add up and will never
attend the last one before a very
special bonus clip is learned to deal
with stress if you want to learn to deal
with stress put yourself in stressful
situations that are under some kind of
control you know even something like
paintball you know we do gigs and
echelon front where we put people
through what we call ft X's where you go
out and you're gonna fire we usually use
airsoft
because it's a little bit more it's a
little easier to work with but actually
what we started using now is we've got
these high end laser tag guns and so
that's that's what we use and they are
super effective they're they're they're
awesome they're awesome training tools
like
if we would had him if we would have if
they would have existed when I was in
the SEAL Teams I would have used him
that because they're that good so we use
those and we put people in stressful
situations go hit this target there's
bad guys you know people are gonna get
shot there's people yelling put yourself
in stress from stressful situations and
learn to detach put yourself in
stressful situations with the purpose of
learning to detach and stepping back
mentally to figure out what's going on
now I've got a special bonus gift from
Jocko a link on how to lead properly
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to taking
action here we go
question number one what are the things
that matter that you need to focus on
number two what mistake have you made
that you have learned from and number
three how will you just do more this
week common misperception right is that
you know the military and the seals I
say this all time everyone thinks that
the military in the seals I think that
we're leading terminator robots right
and everyone is just driven and they're
gonna get up they're gonna do everything
and it's I just talked about this on the
last podcast it is a bell curve it is a
bell curve and there's a great bunch of
guys at the top of the bell curve that
are go-getters there's a solid bunch
guys in the middle and there's a lo of
guys that are bums and so this
interpretation that the concepts that I
talked about are just for leading these
front running a personalities that just
make everything happen mmm
not direct you know there are seals that
don't want to work there are seals that
want to take shortcuts there are seals
that want to escape by then you get
outside then you're working with Iraqi
soldiers that are unmotivated untrained
poorly equipped we got to work with
these guys we got bosses I mean I got
bosses in the SEAL Teams that are either
an egomaniac or that are ultra
risk-averse you can have any of this
stuff going on you can have your guys
that are risk-averse you can have guys
that are too crazy you got all you know
what they are they're humans they're
individuals they're human beings and
because they're human beings even in
Special Operations and sometimes
especially in Special Operations because
when you get in Special Operations you
get guys that
have huge egos and attitudes and so oh
you think that they just want to do
whatever you tell them to do no they got
their own idea that I think our own
method they got their own plan they got
their own what they think they're a
tactical genius so you got to get around
that so what does it mean it means you
have to lead them and it's the common
theme that I'm talking about all time
there was I mean you got to build
relationships
you got to build the trust you got to
make sure they understand why they're
doing what they're doing you got to make
sure they understand the strategic
impact you got to empower them you got
to set a good example you got to listen
to them you got to take input you got to
give them responsibility and and when I
say responsibility I mean real
responsibility you got to build them up
you got to make them better you gotta
show them and let them see not in a not
an A in your face way but you gotta
subtly let them see what self
improvement means them and how they can
better the position and what drive will
get them you got to give them ownership
of stuff and you gotta let that
ownership grow into extreme ownership
where they really want to own things you
got to teach him to lead and you got to
put them in leadership positions and you
gotta show your trust by actually
following them sometimes and again
people ask me these questions you know
I'm a new leader how do I lead I got a
new person how do I leave them it's the
same answers it's the same answers all
the time the principles of leadership
now the nuances are there yes the
nuances are there and I have to nuance
for echo that I got a nuance for this
guy over here and I got a new us for
this group over here the the nuances are
there but the basic principles are the
same am I never am I gonna Who am I
going to be in charge of that I'm not
gonna try and build a relationship of
trust with him whew who's that the
answer is nobody
if you want more Jocko willing check out
the top 50 rules really are made the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there when people are not
going anywhere when they're when they're
failing when they're when they don't
have the drive it's because they're not
accepting responsibility for anything